for almost a century it was accepted
that the holes in Swiss cheese came from
carbon dioxide produced by the
fermentation bacteria that convert milk
to cheese and that that just sort of
happened automatically that's written in
countless articles it's what's all over
the internet and it's almost true about
30 years ago swiss cheese makers start
to notice that the holes the technical
term is eyes were getting smaller and
less frequent and scientists wanted to
work out why specifically the scientists
here at agroscope a Swiss
government-backed agricultural research
facility where for science they have a
lot of samples of cheese and more
importantly samples of the bacteria that
make it
skim milk and about one to five billion
cells lactic acid bacteria per
milliliter you have a shelf life of
about 10 to 14 days so all year round
every week the cultures are freshly made
and sent to our customers we are in
research station we have our collection
of strains but we are also producer for
these cultures we have the genomes of
almost all the bacteria that we have in
the collection here and we know what
parts of the genome are responsible for
some effects on the cheese from the
beginning of the 20th century the
microbiologist went to the different
dairies all over Switzerland and took
the cheese on different products like
whey or the Natural Way cultures
and isolated bacteria from there at that
time each cheese Dairy had its own
culture to produce its own cheese and
each one of these cultures was the
result of decades or centuries of
evolution of selection many of these
dairies had to close down or they
switched to the commercial starter
cultures and these bacteria that made up
their cultures would have disappeared if
they hadn't been collected so the
collection still expounds we have around
000 isolates all the strains of our
collection are frozen at minus 80
degrees and for the most important ones
we also freeze dry them each strain that
we store here has a backup on another
site so each cheese has its own unique
bacterial culture stored in the archive
back there and regularly produced in
these bioreactors the difference between
emmental and grayer is partly to do with
technique but it's also the back
interior that make it and those bacteria
are valuable all the the bacteria that
we have here in the collection are owned
by the Swiss dairy industry to have a
competitive Advantage our bacteria are
not better than other bacteria but they
are very Regional very special some of
the cheese types are legally protected
and to do that they have to use some
special bacteria we call them marker
bacteria because they bear a very
specific sequence of DNA that we are
able to detect in the cheese during the
production but also at the end of the
ripening and by detecting this small
piece of DNA we are able to say okay
this is the right cheese it turns out
that cheese fraud is a thing there's a
market for fake cheap Swiss cheese and
in everyday English particularly in
North America there's also no
distinction between Swiss type cheese
and the specific Swiss cheeses that are
made here near the Alps the ones that
have legal protected status marked on
the packaging so Swiss dairies can work
with the researchers here they can order
the bacterial cultures or just get
advice but it is strictly just for the
industry in Switzerland there are Trade
Secrets here that are guarded carefully
and which I was not allowed to even see
let alone film we regularly develop new
cultures together with the cheese
industry but because you have always to
wait the ripening time for the cheeses
it takes always several years to develop
a new culture so a few years ago the
team here had to answer the question
why aren't there holes in the cheese
anymore we produce here the cheese but
then they go down to the cellar most of
the cheeses have to age between three
months and 12 months at several time
points we take samples to analyze them
in the laboratory for the analysis of
the holes we use X-ray and we use also
computer tomography so then we really
can count the holes but we also see the
distribution in the cheese the bacteria
that are responsible for making these
holes produce propionate acetate and
carbon dioxide and this carbon dioxide
is produced in the cheese and Aggregates
all around impurities the more the
bacterium produces this this carbon
dioxide it accumulates and builds these
holes this impurities capture the carbon
dioxide and then bubble forms and grows
they found that the milk was too clean
so we didn't have any dust in it and
this was because we had closed milking
systems so the dust could not cut into
the milk everything improved the last
decade so the milking process is
hermetically closed now and then in
former times the in the barn you had
always this hay dust everywhere and it
came also into the milk we tried
different particles to put into the milk
to see if the holes are growing again
hay powder is the best one and we really
could see that the whole formation was
dependent on the concentration of the
hay powder we put it in it it's only one
milligram per thousand liters modern
food safety standards mean that milk is
far cleaner now than it ever was in the
past without the tiny well these days
it's imperfections in the past it would
have been contaminants but without those
if the milk is perfectly clean the holes
just don't form and while those holes
don't really affect the taste they
certainly affect whether swiss cheese
looks like sweet questions